rien alors je peux vous demander votre
opinion sur les élections à venir mais
j'ai quand même envie de vous demander
pourquoi on vous a si peu entendu dans
cette campagne présidentielle et si je
vous demande c'est que je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se pose la question
pourquoi yves montand et vous on vous a
pas entendu prendre parti et ça a étonné
plus d'un ça aurait pas dû étonner parce
qu'on n'a jamais jamais jamais pris
parti officiellement ouvertement dans
les consultations aussi colossal que des
consultations électorales parce que on
pense que finalement des gens comme nous
on est plutôt des pense bêtes pour
petites causes en grand danger d'être
oublié auquel cas à ce moment là il faut
se manifester enfin on pense nous qu'il
faut se manifester c'est à dire pour des
choses très ponctuel très précises quand
il ya une injustice ne peut pas on
contient un cas judiciaire qui risque
comme ça d'être un petit peu oubliée
alors là ça vaut le coup de montrer
qu'on est visible vous voulez dire que
là pour faire tandis que les verts et
oui notre cerveau pas le coup non je ne
pense pas que ça vaille le coup je pense
pas que ce soit je pense que chacun a
tellement d'informations pour faire une
chose tellement exceptionnellement grave
exceptionnellement importantes que de
que de décider derrière un petit rideau
quel papier au métronome dans la boîte
oui t'es pas pu remettre dans
l'enveloppé je pense que enfin on sait
prend on se prend pas pour tous pour des
maîtres à penser
c'est en fait partout ailleurs que vous
êtes abstenu aussi de dire aux gens bien
voilà nous on vote ça on va vous dire
que nous on votre ça et on vous appelle
à voter ça ça aussi c'est aussi une
espèce de façon de se tenir très à
l'écart de toute espèce de pouvoir pas
du pouvoir mais alors là j'ai retrouvé
aussi noble dans vos offres complètes
une phase intéressante vous allez me
dire c'est écrit quoi en 75 76 75 62
15 85 76 alors voilà voilà ce que vous
écrivez vous allez me dire si vous re
signer ça aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
allés à l'elysée quand de gaulle nous y
invite et nous n'y sommes pas allés
camper d'où nous y invite et nous
n'irions pas davantage à l'elysée si
c'était mitterrand qui nous y invitait
ce n'est pas une attitude agressive
c'est une prise de distance par rapport
au pouvoir quel que soit le pouvoir ce
qui ne veut pas dire que c'est un
président de la république quel qu'il
soit venait un jour visiter un plateau
sur lequel nous travaillons c'est agassi
venez chez nous lui et non pas nous à sa
table nous refuse de nous refuserions de
tailler une bavette ou de boire un coup
à la cantine avec lui à nos frais retire
absolument rien de ce qu'a dit mme rabe
le test c'est à dire que vous n'y est à
dire que vous n'irez pas à l'elysée si
on vous y invite pas plus aujourd'hui
avec mitterrand que vous l'avez été
autrefois avec les diverses président de
la république successifs
absolument je vous ferai remarquer que
j'étais prémonitoire vous aviez parlé
pas de giscard c'est tout impossible
donc donc vous acceptez que c'est un
c'est presque un petit peu prétentieux
ça veut dire à eux de venir chez nous
mais nous on non on veut rien avoir à
faire avec vous au vous pouvez prendre
ça pour de la prétention je prends c'est
moins pour de l'orgueil ce qui est tout
à fait autre chose qu'il souhaite
anciens et aussi pour une totale
nani comment je pourrais dire c'est
difficile à exprimer moi ça me paraît
très claire volonté doit pas la
dépendance de 2,2 par rapport à la
puissance du pouvoir
je crois que vous avez l'impression que
vous seriez compromis prendre tâche et
il faut pas les rays mois comme aller
chez nom de compromis c'est pas vrai
c'est pas le mot c'est faire copain avec
ben voila vous faites pas copains je
crois qu'on a compris ne pas faire ne
pas faire copain entre guillemets ça
veut pas dire pas être avec est tout à
fait nouveau oui je crois qu'on a
compris et